Continuing in al-wajiz in the book of
purification.
In the chapter regarding the various
types of najasa, the types of filth
as outlined by the Quran and Sunnah.
,
let's see if we can review. We've
mentioned four thus far.
The first two are
urine and feces.
Just urine and feces?
Huh?
What's that?
No, we didn't say that. Hu- human human
urine and feces, right?
Human urine and fe- Okay, that's one and
two. And three and four?
[Arabic recitation]
Al mani.
Al mani is pure.
Huh?
A- Al madhi. Al madhi.
Wal wadhi. Okay, good.
So, that's four of them.
Number one and two.
Human
urine and feces.
Three and four.
Al madhi.
Wal wadhi.
Okay.
So, we said there's there's three that
sound that kind of rhyme, okay?
Al mani.
Wal madhi.
Wal wadhi.
Okay. Mani is what?
With a noon, semen. And that is pure or
filthy?
Pure. Okay.
Number two.
Al
Al madhi.
And that is
No, that's the other one.
This is for arousal. Yes, this is
pre-sperm
or pre-semen.
It comes out during arousal and it is
it is signified as being or described or
its signature
is that it is
transparent. It is it is clear,
right? And it does not come out. It has
its own features. This comes out during
arousal, okay? And its ruling is that it
is what?
Pure or filthy?
Filthy, okay. And then we have a wedy.
And wedy is what?
This is
after urinating, yes. This is after
urinating and it is described as being
cloudy. Cloudy white cloudy, right? Not
really white.
many, which is semen, that is usually
white.
medy is clear. Wedy is cloudy, right?
It comes out after urinating. And its
ruling is pure or or najis?
Najis, okay. And then you wash it, okay.
Number five.
The feces of an animal which is
impermissible to eat.
We could go as far as to say the feces
and urine of the animal which is
impermissible to eat.
The feces and urine of the animal which
is impermissible to eat. As a matter of
fact, we could even expand this even
more and we can say
any part of the animal which is
impermissible to eat which is a part
of the animal. A part
of the animal. The the words here are
very
important to be specific.
Part of the animal.
that does not include hair. Hair is
not technically part of the animal. Hair
in itself is is is dead. It doesn't have
blood flowing through it, okay? Same
thing with nails.
Same thing with teeth. They do not have
blood flowing through them. Contrary to
bones, bones are a part of the animal.
However, teeth,
hair,
nails, claws, right?
These are not considered in Islamic law
as being part of the animal.
Which means that it is permissible to
use any nail,
tooth, or hair of any animal. You've
seen
brushes, for instance, that use boar
boar hair.
Boar's hair,
right? Which is boar is a type of wild
pig, but it has very very thick coarse
hair on its back, right? Sometimes this
is used in in hairbrushes or horse
brushes or very coarse brushes. This is
pure this is permissible. It's
permissible to use. Why? Because it is
not considered part of the animal. What
do we mean when we say the word part?
Meaning blood runs through it.
The tabi'in rahimahullah the sahaba
radiyallahu anhu, they did not consider
these features of the animal to be part
of the animal, meaning to be impure as
the animal itself is impure, okay?
But that we'll get to that later. The
author will mention this
in a few chapters.
For our concern here is the feces,
the urine,
and really any of the fluids
or meat that comes from an animal
which is impermissible to eat.
Which is which is inherently
impermissible to eat. All right?
So, we're speaking about
a tiger, a lion,
a panther, a dog, right?
a cat, even a house cat. However,
house cats are exempt from this for a
reason we'll mention later.
But, those wild animals
which are impermissible to eat,
all of their body is considered to be
impure if it is not something that
mixes with humans naturally.
[Silence]
Abdullah ibn Mas'ud says the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam wished to
relieve himself.
And so, he told me,
"Collect for me three stones to use
for
you know, to to clean himself." And
so, I could only find two stones that
were appropriate and one dried piece of
you know, manure from a
donkey, right? A donkey meaning a
domestic donkey. Domestic donkey is
haram to eat, okay?
And so, I brought him the three and he
threw away the
the domestic donkey, the donkey's
manure, and kept the two rocks and said,
"It is a regis one. Regis one yani najis
one. It is
impure. It is considered filthy."
so, the ruling here that is to be
taken is that any animal which is
impermissible to eat,
inherently impermissible to eat, meaning
there's no possible way to slaughter it
in a way that makes it halal.
It is haram any way you slice it, right?
This animal,
its urine and feces are considered to be
a regis. It's considered to be najis.
And
along with that
goes the sweat, the saliva, the
blood, the
pus,
you know, anything that comes from this
animal.
And so, there are exceptions to that.
And those exceptions have to do with how
difficult it is for a person to
reasonably
protect himself from those kinds of
things. So, for instance,
a domestic donkey is haram to eat,
right? Domestic donkey is haram to eat
bil ijma.
Okay, consensus-wise.
Now, a domestic donkey is haram to eat.
However, being that we use domestic
donkeys for exactly what they sound, and
that is domestic, right? We ride on
them, we carry our stuff on them, we
have them around. Okay? These are
extremely common animals. How reasonable
is it to expect someone to completely
protect himself from sweat, saliva,
urine, feces, especially when these
things use the bathroom in the street.
We can't stop them from doing that. How
reasonable is it to protect your clothes
entirely 100% from it? It's difficult.
It's unreasonable.
A house cat, we call a house cat, right?
these things are important to
humanity. As a matter of fact, house
cats have a history of saving entire
civilizations from collapse because of
disease.
Because house cats
they take care of what? Pests that carry
disease mice, rats,
things that. They are considered to
be one of the types of servants of human
beings, as the prophet put it,
sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
Plus, they are pets for as long back as
humans can remember, and they're real
cute, and kids to play with them,
and whatever else it is, right? And so
how reasonable would it be to have cats
around? I mean, imagine
we're living back in, you know,
100 or 200 years ago, even here in
America, even 50 years ago.
Even 100 or 150 years ago when they came
to Tucson to have it as a mining town,
right? And it was a small little town,
but this was the
western frontier. And now we're living
in in a little town or a little village.
And we've got this desert around us.
What is very dangerous for us.
Scorpions,
snakes,
all these things which they are still
dangerous, right? But things are a
little bit more locked off.
The city is much bigger now.
But we still have these problems.
Well, how do you
sleep at night with these kinds of
things?
Cat Cats are a very big
resource, huge resource for human
beings, right?
They're They're one of the kinds of
animals that help us
to
you know, travel the world and and
conquer areas and lands and
and build towns and cities and stay
safe and so forth.
So, how reasonable would it be to
not have a cat
have its saliva
get on anything in the house?
It's very It's almost impossible, right?
And this is why the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam
gives us a leniency for things that we
use
and things that would essentially
coexist with us.
All right? a domestic donkey, like
a house cat, like
a hunting dog, right? The saliva of a
hunting dog. Dog saliva is
filthy. However, if it is taught and
if it is a hunting dog, it's being used
for hunting, then its saliva is not
filthy.
Right?
Why is that?
Cuz
how am I going to have a dog hunt with
me and grab stuff with its mouth and
then
you know, have to consider everything it
catches to be filthy. I might as well
just not have it. It would be
easier than in that situation.
So, these things are given an allowance
in Islam, right? The prophet says with
respect to the house cat in the house
and the house cat
he said it is not
the cat is not filthy, meaning it's
saliva.
Right?
Indeed, it is of the servants that Allah
has given you. The
servants.
Right? Just we have
human servants that help us, we also
have
animal servants that help us, and house
cats are one of them. We call them house
cats, domestic cats, right?
And this has its own chapter as well.
But, what did we learn today? We learned
today that
the fifth type of filth is the animal
which is impermissible to eat. It is
inherently filthy.
It's urine and feces, it's saliva, it's
fluids, unless it it is exempted because
of common use.
Unless it is exempted of common use.
Second thing we learned is hair.
Something that doesn't have blood flow
through it on the animal. Hair,
tooth,
nail,
claw, talon, these things are pure
of any animal. Even if it is off of a
pig.
Even if it is off of a dog.
It is considered to be what?
Pure.
Number three,
we learned
this issue of these domesticated animals
and the leniency and their purity
because of how difficult it would be to
reasonably
coexist with these animals and you know,
everything becomes filthy over time if
that were the case and that would be far
too tedious for us to be able to
practice.
[Silence]
Is this your sign?